so yeah the double attack is really just
one of the most important tactics
because you find it in all areas of the
game and these any piece can commit a
double attack and generally in chess you
always want to be doing two things with
every move if not more if possible like
you can be very generous with thinking
about doing two things with every move
right like when you play e4 you're
developing your bishop and you're
developing your plane right so there's a
sense in which every move in chess
you're doing multiple purses purposes
usually but I'm just going to show you
some of the double tax that occur in the
opening and then we'll go to some other
ones the first one which I've seen the
most strong players probably fall into
is against the Sicilian defense so
what's the most popular move in this
position what's up
d4 is the most popular move what other
moves are popular in this position c3 is
a c3 somewhat popular yeah any other
Bishop b5 check excellent that's a good
move as well so Bishop b5 check c3 d4
anything else
b4 you mean before is occurs sometimes
this is a little rare
there's also Bishop c4 which sometimes
people play you can also play Knight c3
so all kind of normal ways to play
against the Sicilian but by far the most
popular is to play d4 Wyatt why is d4
such a popular move
yeah this is just this is just a nice
way to continue developing and try to
get a really quick development
especially considering the fact that
blacks first couple moves didn't promote
one of the main goals in chess openings
which is to do what to develop pieces
and castle right so White's going to be
really aggressive hoping that to take
advantage of that instead in the game
that we're going to look at white played
c3 and now after Knight to f6 you see a
very frequent mistake here
white plays Bishop to e2 what do we
think of that move well what happens if
black plays Knight takes pawn exactly
Queen to a4 checks so this is a pretty
common example of double attack in the
opening and I've seen a lot of people
play that so instead what would you play
here as black so the double attack
Knight AC for allowing Queen to a4 and
it's a check and you can't stop the fact
that I'm going to also capture your
knight well yeah the right move in this
position is for black to play knight c6
oh you mean to play it originally well
sometimes people just sometimes people
play Knight f6 to attack the pawn first
and because when you play knight c6 you
know they could also transpose into
Bishop b5 stuff so a lot of times
they've start with Knight f6 and then
after you see what I mean like it's
Knight f6 Bishop you to if you now play
knight c6 you'd be losing a move if you
play Bishop b5 so just a little bit of a
move order thing so now what if white if
white plays d4 can black capture the
pawn what happens now if black captures
upon somebody somebody not here raise
your hand
Arlie funny was he talking about double
attacks do i think you somebody asked oh
it was like a game so the game analysis
right you were the one who sent me a
game right okay cool so what can what
you do now double attacks are constantly
popping up in chests in all phases of
the game
exactly it's just you just have to see
one move further right
you start with d5 attacking the night
and then when the knight moves wherever
it moves now you can play queen day for
a check so the pawn on e4 is still taboo
but that's one a big example of double
attack in the opening another example
that you sometimes see especially in
beginners games is stuff where say they
play like this now let's evaluate how
would you try to go for a double attack
in this position okay so you might play
d4 hitting this Bishop right now say
black were to put the bishop back here
now what's the idea what can white play
here somebody somebody else how can help
him wait to middle for care commits a
fork I don't know if that makes any
sense sounds good though execute a fork
it's probably better yes so d5 and and
that's just good for white right because
we're going to win either in the night
or the bishop for a pond so instead I
mean life is not usually so simple
that's why I showed this example like
sometimes even if you analyze and you
say yes I'm going to win a piece because
I'm going to play d4 and then d5 if your
opponent plays a little bit better than
that it won't end up that great so would
black play instead here yeah somebody
else so how play better for black Sal
what do you think
okay that's why you take a pawn to start
that's fine and then after I take back
let's totally find a day first
momentarily just for one move but the
threat is renewed if you were to play
Bishop back I would play d5 again and
have a double attack anyway hmm
if you take with a knight I've got too
many pieces on it right I take back and
I'm going to be ahead material now this
uses another tactic usually tactics and
chests are not cut and dried there's
usually some combination of tactics like
it's either a double attack plus a pin
or a double attack plus removal of the
guard you lose like different things
going on in this case it's double attack
and what's the other principle at play
here that black can try to use to get
out of it swooshing zoo anybody know it
swishing Zerg means in English that's a
German word for probably the most
important tactic at the Grand Master or
Master level the most important tactic
at the Grand Master our master level I
would say is swishing zhuge which is
known as in-between move right in
between move is a move that you try to
stick in the variation so that your
opponent can't do exactly what they
wanted to do and usually it's a move
where you're getting attacked but you
create a check or an attack on a piece
that's more important so that you can
gain some time yeah
avoid the double attack yeah uh-huh
exactly Bishop takes Bishop and now when
Bishop takes Bishop you see that you're
going to get out of it because if once I
recapture the bishop can move and now
everything is fine for black work
because what if white plays Bishop takes
Bishop no instead of capturing back the
pawn with by Bishop takes Bishop first
right okay well queen bee three attacks
b7 and u6 at the same time which is kind
of a double attack but at least it
doesn't lose a piece now if you had to
choose well first of all this is a good
place to point out the concept of double
defense right we talked about double
attack attacking two things at once but
we can also double defend defend two
things at once how can you defend both
the pawn on b7 an e6 at once here yeah
exactly Queen c8 so that's why I like to
think about double attack more broadly
because a lot of times in chess it's not
just about attacking two things at once
it's just about doing two things at once
period so let's take a look at some
examples in the middle game of double
attack double attack can really occur in
any opening all right well this is a
cool example of a double attack
yeah if you know what right away well
it's a little easier based on um based
on the theme of the lesson this is just
a very cool position which it's a good
one to jot down in your notebook to show
to friends so wait to move in win it
looks like it's a totally dead draw
because we've got one work verse another
rock right usually that's a drawl and
they somebody hangs a rock right so what
can we play here you've got two people
who've got it let's just see if a couple
more people can get it before we move on
then time in here in the front rows not
totally short you've seen this one
before you've heard this one before
everybody else is genuinely puzzled we
got another one okay next person gets a
regular will actually call on can't wait
for everyone to get it it's I think we
got like up
you've got like four people or something
you solved it
yeah anyone else you got an answer over
there
this one is one where you got to be sure
you know all the roles of chasse was
that too big of a hit yeah all right
yeah and in the back of the glasses yeah
now oh you remember it okay so well so
yeah well they haven't canceled yeah
yeah
they haven't yes so you do why you queen
give me the move well yeah we call Queen
side castles right
triple oh yes Queen side castles and
this is a exactly that to this is a very
pretty double attack a cool position
it'll be really fun if you could get
that in a real game one that I would
love that
hmm so you can even double attack while
castling let's look at another one so
this is white to move what do you think
it what would be your first candidate
move if you are right here
the first thing that you would play if
you were white
well that's one thing you might consider
playing but like if you were if you
looked at the board the first second
what what move would you probably look
at solely to see my gonna discovered
attack
well you might look in 96 but then you
realize Queen takes g6 check you might
look at night takes rock what happens if
Knight takes wreck that's the best way
to play here see if somebody can do this
there's actually a maid in about five
here for black well you could play Queen
takes rook but you've got before you
before you play that move you want to
make sure it's the very best because
worst case scenario is white now I could
just take your knight and now you know
the situation's not so bad for me right
I'm up a pawn and everything seems fine
so especially in positions where you
have multiple forcing moves
I know Ronan talked a lot about forcing
moves and it's such an important concept
you don't want to just go for the first
one you see like oh I can take her up
great you wanna make sure you say well
what about that check what about that
check what about that capture right
that's a nice little chest expression
find a good move look for a better one
and I would definitely agree with that
especially in a case where there's
multiple checks and captures what I tell
my students is anytime there's a check a
capture or a checkmate threat at least
take a look at it doesn't mean you have
to play it but at least look at it so
anyone want to try to checkmate in five
moves here
yes all right let's do in our heads to
start all right so Queen to g6 well I'm
going to if I play King h1 somebody else
tell me why there's maiden one exactly
so instead I'll play King to f1 that
gives me a better chance of survival
because now if you played Queen G to
check at least I could play King you on
so after King f1 what's the best move
well you're actually on g6 now all right
so once you play Queen g6 check queen
bee one check good and then let's say I
play King to a queen that you on okay
good and then I play King to g1
excellent so the cool thing about that
is that you're just basically going back
to the original position except now the
Queen's on you one blocking the escape
square so it's a force mate right videos
Queen g6 check King F one queen bee one
Queen e1 Queen d3 check King G g1 and
we've basically gone on a whole circle
but it's been a worthwhile a circle
because now it's actually checkmate on
g2 so that leads us back to the original
position actually taking that work off
one c8 would be a horrendous blunder
instead white needs to play what I think
a couple of people mentioned at the
beginning of the lesson but let's see if
a couple more people can get it so other
forcing moves 96 check didn't work out
because of Queen takes Deus Ex which
actually would be mating Knight takes c8
allows black to mate but white still has
one very good move here Sal Oh 96 was
mentioned but if Nike six check then the
Queen can capture on g6 with check and
then we're going to also come in to g2
and things will look very ugly indeed so
what were you going to say
yeah you know you're looking at me like
you know the answer yeah yes take the
night to yours taking the night and this
is a very common motif where you
sacrifice the Queen and then you get to
play Knight to g6 Jack and now you're
left piece in the end of the variation
and we'll see a more complicated event
example of that in a second so here how
about this position this is white to
move this is from a game where Judit
Polgar the strongest woman in chess
history is playing against Vishy Anand
who is best known for being white
yes the current world champion so it's
good to know who the current world
champion is now a lot of people don't
know who a man is as like a lot of
average people in India nons extremely
famous but right now I'd say in the
Western press there is a player who's
way more well-known than and on even
though he's not the current world
champion Who am I talking about
yeah Magnus Carlsen is the world number
one rated player so there's that kind of
confusion in the chess world where the
world champions not always the number
one rated but obviously that happens in
lots of other sports too so not really
that's strange
so this one's white to move take our
time on this for just a minute because
even if you already got I want to give
people other people a quick chance
so where's your hand if you got it 1 2 3
4 5 ok good what do you think this work
the eight seven and then after king
takes 8 7 ok Knight takes bishop and now
what do you think of blacks best move is
in this position so very good try
because if work takes f6 now Queen takes
d7 check and blacks went and whites
winning right but what what what a what
good move does black have er well
actually huh
maybe remove mmm no no anything black
has a defense area one of one of the
defenses I thought he had doesn't quite
work that yeah so King eight six and now
if Knight takes Queen black and play why
yeah and then blacks actually doing well
he's up in exchange right so the the
problem there the problem with your
calculation there was just that it's
it's not exactly it's not totally
forcing right so you just need to
visualize a position that's that was a
really good try though and I think it's
a common example of what's wrong with
certain calculations it especially when
you're in the business of sacrificing
you kind of have to double triple check
whereas when you're playing a regular
position and you're just like saying
moving or work to an open file you don't
really have to double or triple check
your analysis it's just like oh this is
probably a good move right there's any
time you sacrifice something you really
gotta make absolutely sure that you
don't leave any any stone unturned in
your opponent's defenses so the key
thing here is move order move order is a
very important concept in calculation
and tactics a lot of times when you have
an idea that almost works if you tweak
the move order the order of moves that
you play it will suddenly work what did
you have in mind
you said you had the answer in the
position so you want to play if I hear
what do you think of Blackwood you hear
well if he takes the night I mean that
actually looks pretty good too
yeah that looks good as well yeah easy
this this doesn't really lead to
anything right and then it's not mate
yeah so I can like I can still play King
eight seven or something and I have the
extra rock right I was also thinking
that you could you can maybe just take
the rook off immediately as well it kind
of leads to the same thing yeah so II
five doesn't quite work here so it's
usually harder to find tactics when
there's a number of ideas yeah yeah
similar concept is before I asked so
somehow all the move orders are being
tried but you really need to get the
perfect one yeah exactly so Queen takes
and that's what you thought - I believe
you don't worry I could tell about your
like green pegs bishop and then after
rook takes now what and now work to h7
exactly
so see how we use exactly the same idea
that he came up with but by switching
the move order it became went from
losing exchange to actually winning a
full piece so very nice position and one
of the things about double attacks is
you can do it with any piece right a
pawn can double attack a king can double
attack a bishop every piece can do a
double attack what's the most common
piece to give a double attack would you
think what do we see the most often yeah
yeah we probably seen the Knights more
often than any other piece especially in
games they sometimes leave like the c7
or the f7 pawn hanging but what do you
think I see the least of and probably
not because you get things like d4
probably the king what would you do here
no this can't be white to move because
then white would play work takes king x
clan no it's black so what do you guys
what do you guys think of the position
for black is a question
alright good thing give me some analysis
to think about it a little longer and
then give me some analysis
I think well let's look at the okay
that's good let's look at the normal
moves first just because they also
involve some double attacks believe it
or not so what would it be the first
thing that you would think about playing
here is black well mind you consider
playing you might consider moving the
King right because you're in check so if
the King moves to e8 what would white do
okay if you the King goes eh the white
work goes to e7 chat and then what do
you think black would do then what's
that called exactly so if the King goes
to e8 work v7 check King f8 and now you
can play for instance work to a 7 with a
discovered attack also known as Abu
attack and then you get to capture the
Queen on a5 next move right right
exactly so if he goes to d8 after wiki 7
check then we have a double attack with
one Bishop c7 check right and then even
though he gets its capture our rook we
play Bishop takes Queen and the position
is pretty equal
yeah just totally symmetrical someplace
suppose somebody's we have to do
something really stupid to lose I think
ah ha ha ha yeah it's some people are
worse than games in others so we instead
what happens if a black plays after
instead he decides he doesn't want to
play King aid and he plays King da what
happens on King d8
so somebody want to show me they
checkmate in two what do you think got
it no I'm asking a in front of you see
yeah we should be seven and then just
after can be eight
well actually it works eh not the right
mouth yeah because the work is that the
work on c7 is actually performing a
useful function of protecting the bishop
on e7 right so instead Knight to d6 is
checkmate though right so this is mate
so what should black and do instead in
this position and black to move and
actually win surprisingly despite all
that black has a win here
see if one or two or more people can get
it
anyone else got an idea yeah you're
nodding Queen takes work and then and
then what's the deal mm-hmm what would
why can't recapture with right the way
would rehab for the bishop and then
black plays exactly now king c6
attacking the bishop and the knight and
that's actually exactly the double
attack that you had prepare her right so
you must have seen this really quickly
when I asked him to construct a double
attack this was the exact one that he
put on the board yeah so the the knight
has to move and then the bishop falls so
if you can see I mean these double
attacks they can be very simple like I
wasn't sure that for the class before
this I was going to show them some some
really simple double attacks as it
turned out some of the some of the
people didn't know the moves of the
rules of the of chess so I wasn't sure
about that but you know they can be
absolutely simple right like let's go
through all the really simple ones very
quickly
Bishop c3 check right you can call them
out if you want so
- a double attack with a pond right with
f4 check so it can be very complicated
like the example that we looked at with
Queen takes bishop and followed by work
to h7 check - extremely simple and
that's a cool thing about this tactic
it's really true with almost all tactics
here's another one that's a little bit
more complicated so what would you do
here is white and take your time
I'm sorry actually I think the position
setup wrong yeah there's there's a piece
missing
let me just I'll fix that yeah right the
ghost
let's see if there's somebody let's see
what everybody thinks
because you got a couple of tempting
ideas in this position
a lot of tempting ideas see what
different ideas we have what would you
think about playing there nyeeehhh six
with the first move occur to you any
other ideas or is everybody basically
set on that move
what about decided Kirk so I actually I
I agree ninety six is the best move and
it looks like White's doing really well
now because you're just going to pick up
an exchange because they can't recapture
because then there's another double
attack right but why is obvi six not a
good move
this is something that a lot of lot of
players you know sometimes get confused
about like why wouldn't Bishop e6 be
equally good with the idea that they
take you can take back with a knight and
fork their two rocks what's the
difference Sal well okay so there's not
a variation where you actually end up
winning the Queen sure exactly right so
if if they capture here and you can you
take back with a knight even though your
fortune the two rooks black could for
instance move well actually the position
black can make work to f7 and then after
Knight ACA Queen takes d8 it's still
probably good for white honestly because
of all these pawns but it's it's not
completely kaput like the other position
yeah what was your question after after
what yeah that's a good question so
Bishop e6 after 26 just pawn takes well
I have to play Queen c8 basically
alright it's true yeah that does look
pretty good too because if you play you
summon immediately I could check but one
thing I could do here is I could start
with rook takes and then after rook
takes then I could play Queen here still
looks pretty dangerous after he seven
now same thing it's also like it looks
totally devastating anyway although I
guess no maybe I could play Knight takes
Knight here though yeah I forgot about
that move that looks pretty it's true
but it's not it's not as clear you
cannot put all your good pawns and I and
I end up with the e4 pawn right like
after pawn takes excuse me
in this position like this is not this
is not nearly as good as the other lines
we were looking at right because black
heads just like weather the storm and
even avoid this up in exchange black
heads is pawn on e4 and it's just not as
clear as any of the other things yeah in
what's in which line which one
so Queen here now here if you play Queen
b3 here
my first instinct is going to be let's
see well interfering with the knight
here is probably probably going to be
the bass yeah yeah and this is not
totally clear all right all right so
good job though 96 is is way easier and
you know doesn't allow for all that
messiness so let's show one more all
right so here we go this one is a black
to move physician it's probably the
hardest one I've shown you so take our
time
so black to move and win or get a really
good position rather
this is a tactic that definitely uses a
lot of different themes not just double
attack usually more complicated the more
likely it is to be a combination of
themes not just one Rex what Queen a5 is
attacking the pawn on a to what do you
think the best defense would be
therefore right there is one only I
guess there's really only one good
defense
yeah b3 is a pretty good defense though
because then once you play once you play
Queen a5 once I play b3 it's not clear
how you follow up on that everything
seems to be reasonably well defended and
you I know like you would probably like
to play Queen a3 and then like get a
work to a5 but that's very difficult to
do actually it's kind of funny if you
play Queen a5 and I play b3 and you play
Queen a3 then like say I just play some
random move like h5 and you play a 5
what can white do uh-huh yeah but should
be two traps the Queen
it's pretty funny line
I'm just showing you a self-made of the
Queen mm-hmm but you've got the right
idea that there is like a temporary
looseness on the a2 of Honor we talk
about loose pieces but it's also
important there's an expression loose
pieces drop off which refers to the fact
that when you have a rook that's on a
square where the works not defended it's
it's liable to things like double
attacks discovered attacks but there's
also loose points right a - is for the
moment it's defended by the king but
it's still a little bit tender and so
that's why I move like Queen a if I
should definitely always be on your list
of candidate moves this is another case
where move order might come into play
so move order is really key here
all right yeah you got an idea okay so
Bishop takes a to check let I think you
probably have the idea because you seem
to be getting a lot of questions right
so let's see if somebody else can jump
off from this idea and see what you had
in mind so what's your name again so
Julian mentions bishop takes a to check
sacrificing the bishop now what do you
think the idea is after King takes a to
somebody else try to follow up on
Julian's attack so Queen a5 check is
that that might be his idea but then was
that what you were going to play that
was what you're going to play okay if
you play Queen to a5 check there's a
couple of moves there for what would
you're going to do after King to be one
let somebody else try to figure out so
what are you going to do after King to
be one so you want to play Bishop to a
to check King takes a two and then Queen
to a5 Jack and then King to b1
pawn to b3 okay and what does that do
exactly so and what else is a
threatening like what if we just play
pawn takes pawn
not exactly because if Bishop Dixie -
Kim you a - queen a5 check King b1 b3 if
we take on b3 and you play work c1 check
we can still recapture with the rock
right so I think Julian had something
else in mind
oh that's okay Julian what did you have
in mind exactly so that's where the SS
hat comes in so he's not trying to make
you any of that at any point now he's
just capturing that loose rook on D to
the concept of loose pieces drop off
right
so again Bishop takes a to check King a
to Queen a5 check and now what would you
have done if I played King to b3 instead
anybody else want to answer that
it looks pretty dangerous right
you mean queen-to-be five check okay and
now if I play Bishop c4 you just play
Queen takes c4 if you place c4 what
happens now this one is important you
got to see this one yes you got to pick
on Poisson excellent take on pass on and
now again it's kind of a double attack
you're you're checking the king and
you're attacking this rock right so
that's totally winning so really the
only thing that you would be worried
about here would be king takes pawn that
would be the only one that would require
much calculation rather so work to be a
check and now what would you do if your
opponent played King to a3
Queen day five you mean Queen night five
right and what would you do if your
opponent played King to a four then well
because you can't play if you play Queen
B five yeah so instead they have to play
king b1 and then this move it's hard to
see from the initial position but now
that we got it here it becomes a lot
more obvious right that when you play b3
it's creating a double attack with the
the queen heading to the square and the
work on d2 hanging so and this was from
a grandmaster game so like it's very
interesting how the double attacks can
be both beginner fodder where people are
just hanging Forks but they can also be
using very high level games when it
becomes more complicated and it's really
like that with every attack think in
chaste from score to fork to in between
moves so you just got to keep studying
those tactics even if you reach a pre
high level
I know players who are 2600 who you know
before tournaments they'll train with
the tactics trainers